Hampton Falls New Hampshire and one of
the most prestigious streets in the
state it's not the sort of place you'd
expect to find political outsiders but
after years of supporting establishment
Republicans local business leaders Lou
and Marianne Gargiulo have had enough
they now head up their counties Donald
Trump campaign I think that people get
elected they go to Washington in there
there forever and to stay there it
requires them to rely on the special
interests the lobbyists and all of those
people who provide them the funds
necessary to run but is Donald Trump
really the answer many see him as
extreme but Marianne and Lou reject that
they point out that he's relatively
moderate on social issues like gay right
they say the Republican Party has to
catch up you gotta let it go you gotta
listen to the Pope he's sending a very
powerful message the Pope is not saying
it's okay the Pope is saying you have to
forgive and move on and and they have to
take that posture too meanwhile
volunteers are working the phones at a
Bernie Sanders campaign base in a rural
part of the state hi this is Peggy from
the Bernie Sanders campaign is Gary home
right up to the last minute people like
Peggy Greenough are doing three-hour
shifts many New Hampshire voters are
getting tired of all the calls we were
sworn out you know we've had a few
people but campaigning is a serious
business for Peggy a working-class wife
and mother with long-term health
problems she in her son's canvas just
like this for Hillary Clinton eight
years ago but now they see Clinton as a
slave to the big money behind her
campaign thank you to
I don't see how you can be for the
people and do the right thing if you
have people behind you paying you to do
something else you know because you're
going to go where the money goes and you
know where the money comes from it's
like you're gonna you're gonna take care
of your payday you know and she's done a
very good job doing that so and I feel
should continue to do that instead of
taking care of people like us back in
Hampton folds Lou doesn't have much in
common with Peggy but they do agree on
this that a choice between establishment
candidates isn't much of a choice at all
I think that there are plenty of
establishment politicians in Washington
that really don't see a difference
between a bush or Clinton s president
because they know essentially everything
will remain the same when they look at
somebody like a Bernie Sanders or a
Donald Trump they're extremely fearful
that these people would make dramatic
changes dramatic change is exactly what
Peggy and her family are yearning for in
fact as they return to base and even
bigger word is on their minds Bernie
Sanders cool for a political revolution
it's a big word but it's a big time and
it's a big need and I think revolution
is really what needs to be and what it
from my kids to even have something to
look forward to the revolution is hope
for me you know and and what I would
hope what is there and we don't have any
right now so I think you know the
America I want is one with the future oh
you were Peggy and her fellow volunteers
are hoping that that future starts here
but is America really ready for a
revolution or even just an outsider
questions that hang in the air as night
falls in New Hampshire